actor and musician meatloaf is dead as
reported on the evening of january 20th
2022 by deadline the news broke in a
statement from the artist's family
released and circulated by his agent
michael green the statement reads we
know how much he meant to so many of you
and we truly appreciate all of the love
and support as we move through this time
of grief and losing such an inspiring
artist and beautiful man from his heart
to your souls don't ever stop rocking
meatloaf whose real name was originally
marvin lee a day which he later changed
to michael lee a day was a successful
musician and actor arguably best known
for his bad out of hell album trilogy
notably at the center of his success as
a rock musician was his operatic singing
voice many of his hit songs match early
heavy metal influenced guitars to
musical theater s compositions amounting
to a signature rock and roll sound like
few artists to come before or since
meatloaf hit the rockstar jackpot with
his very first album bad out of hell
which came out in 1977 and yielded five
singles including two out of three ain't
bad and paradise by the dashboard light
the bat out of hell album in fact is one
of the best selling albums of all time
ranking 33 on a list by business insider
published in september 2021 its sequel
bad out of hell 2 back into hell granted
him his biggest hit in the chart topping
i'd do anything for love but i won't do
that on a subsequent tour for those
albums meatloaf became known for his
rowdy on-stage antics on top of his
music finally in 2006 he wrapped up the
trilogy with bad out of health 3 the
monster is loose apart from this three
album opus he released numerous other
albums over the course of his career
like the concept album hang cool teddy
bear in 2010. the artist was also a
well-known actor with over 100 acting
credits to his name his early career was
arguably defined by his role as the
greaser eddy in the 1975 cult musical
the rocky horror picture show at a few
points in the film he lends his pipes to
his iconic soundtrack most notably on
hot patootie bless my soul meatloaf also
portrayed robert paulson in 1999's fight
club viewers familiar with the film will
remember the subsequent invocation of
his name as sort of a justification for
the anarchic behavior of project mayhem
group his name is robert paulson other
notable movies to feature a meatloaf
performance include wayne's world spice
world and tenacious d in the pick of
destiny while deadlines reports asserts
that a cause of death is not being
released they reference a claim by tmz
that meatloaf died from complications
resulting from a covet-19 infection
according to tmz sources with knowledge
told the outlet that quote he was
supposed to attend a business dinner
earlier this week for a show he's
working on i'd do anything for love but
the dinner was cancelled because he
became seriously ill with covid later
that condition quickly became critical
he then spent his final moments
alongside his wife and two daughters as
recounted by his manager michael greene
a wide variety of musicians paid tribute
to meatloaf on social media in the wake
of his death including generational pop
artist cher rock singer lenny kravitz
country star travis tritt jack black's
comedy rock duo tenacious d and thrash
metal titans anthrax among plenty of
others actors to memorialize meatloaf
include mistress of the dark elvira star
trek actor george takei and comic
performer thomas lennon the latter of
whom recounted working alongside him on
the pilot for the sketch comedy series
the state judging by the varied
backgrounds of each of these performers
meatloaf's influence prior to his death
purportedly caused by covet 19 was about
as wide-ranging as could be he is
survived by his wife deborah as well as
his daughters pearl and amanda our
thoughts are with the artist's family
and friends during their time of loss
and grief